you know we all have our own individual
stories outside of what happens within
the group
what happened within the group it was
just drama drama drama for me but even
outside the group I had some really like
what moments you know Riley's old enough
to say whether she want to have a
relationship with her dad always good
and Riley's great this year on the show
you see us dealing with the situation
about her father yes I did not know that
he was gonna uh all right the show's got
it
and um that's what I have to say to
people who think that this is scripted
and we know what's gonna happen know
you'll see the story play out but um you
know her father and I we don't have the
best of communication and um you know
hadn't talked to him or seen him for a
while and it was just like surprise he's
here on the show what because I've
always tried to kind of keep that out of
ya you know the story you know I never
really wanted to put that on blast or
whatever I mean people knew I was a
single mom but not really the details of
you know him being not being there or
whatever so you get a little bit more
information on that you said you got go
chasing B or rods happy chase watch how
you should turn on the show I actually
did a song with my daughter about for
her she's seen it that kind of like says
how she feels about her situation you
know I was just kind of like asking her
like well what do you think you know why
don't you talk about how you feel
seriously and um so that's how that song
came about
you